.
>>> 6:00 P.M. IN ABU DHABI.
I'M BECKY ANDERSON AND YOU ARE
WATCHING "CONNECT THE WORLD."
IRAN'S ELECTION PLAYING OUT
ACROSS THE REGION AND FAR
BEYOND.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD OF THIS MAN,
ULTRA CONSERVATIVE CLERIC
EBRAHIM RAISI WILL BE THE NEW
PRESIDENT.
CAUSING GEOPOLITICAL RIPPLES
ALONG WITH QUESTIONS ON THE
STATUS OF THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
LAYING OUT IRAN'S OBJECTIVES IN
A NEWS CONFERENCE TODAY.
RESTORING THE DEAL TO ITS
ORIGINAL PARAMETERS ON THE
UNITED STATES, SAYING THE U.S.
MUST RETURN TO THE DEAL IT
WITHDREW FROM IN EXPEDITED
MANNER.
RAISI SPEAKING OUT ON THE DEAL
AFTER THE LATEST ROUND OF TALKS
TO RESTORE IT, WRAPPED UP IN VEE
ENA.
NEGOTIATORS RETURNING TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES FOR INSTRUCTIONS
AND OFFICIALS FROM BOTH SIDES
ARE NOW SPEAKING OUT.
THE TOP EU OFFICIAL CHAIRING THE
TALKS, SAYING WE ARE CLOSER TO A
DEAL BUT WE ARE STILL NOT THERE.
IRAN'S TOP NUCLEAR NEGOTIATOR
VOICING SIMILAR SENTIMENTS,
SAYING WE ARE NOW CLOSER TO A
DEAL THAN AT ANY TIME IN THE
PAST, BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
WE ARE THERE.
AMERICA'S NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER COMMENTING ON RAISI'S
ELECTION ON CNN.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> THE PERSON WHO MAKES THE
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER IRAN WILL
GO BACK IN TO THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL WILL ASSUME ITS NUCLEAR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER INTERNATIONAL
LAW IS NOT THE PRESIDENT OF
IRAN.
IT IS THE SUPREME LEADER OF
AND THAT PERSON DID NOT CHANGE
FROM BEFORE THE ELECTION UNTIL
AFTER THE ELECTION.
>> WELL, ISRAEL'S NEW PRIME
MINISTER WITH A BLUNT WARNING TO
WORLD LEADERS ABOUT IRAN'S
GOVERNMENT.
NAFTALI BENNETT SAYING IT'S THE
LAST CHANCE FOR WORLD POWERS TO
WAKE UP.
THESE GUYS, HE SAYS, ARE
MURDERERS, MASS MURDERERS.
REPORTERS ARE ALL OVER THE MAP
COVERING THIS STORY TONIGHT FROM
TEHRAN, JERUSALEM.
FRED PLEITGEN IT IS IN TEHRAN,
WHERE HE QUESTIONED THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO PUT A
QUESTION TO EBRAHIM RAISI, THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
WHAT DID YOU ASK HIM?
WHAT DID HE TELL YOU?
>> Reporter: HEY, BECKY, THIS
NEWS CONFERENCE WAS FOR RAISI TO
EXPLAIN HIS POLICY, HE WANTED TO
EXPLAIN TO THE NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL PRESS AS WELL.
FOREIGN POLICY WILL PLAY A BIG
ROLE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE TO KEEP AM MIND EBRAHIM
RAISI WAS ELECTED INTO POWER
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS NOT DOING
WELL AND THERE'S A BIG NEED, AS
MANY SEE IT, TO FIGHT
CORRUPTION.
HE CERTAINLY ALSO SAID THAT IRAN
IS GOING TO HAVE A VERY, VERY
FORCEFUL AND VERY ACTIVE FOREIGN
POLICY AS WELL AND IT CERTAINLY
LOOKS LIKE, FROM WHAT WE HEARD
TODAY AND WHAT I HEARD FROM
EBRAHIM RAISI THAT THE U.S.
WOULD BE IN FOR A TOUGH RIDE.
HE WAS ASKED BY ONE REPORTER IF
HE WOULD EVER SIT DOWN WITH U.S.
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE FLAT OUT SAID NO.
NO EXPLANATION, JUST NO.
I ASKED IF HE WOULD TAKE TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, OR IF HE
WOULD BE WILLING TO ACCEPT AT
LEAST NEGOTIATIONS FOR SOMETHING
LIKE AN EXPANDED NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT.
LET'S LISTEN IN TO WHAT HE HAD
TO SAY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, SIR, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TAKING OUR
QUESTION.
YOU'VE ALREADY TOLD US HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT A DIRECT MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
BUT WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO TALK
TO AND NEGOTIATE WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
WOULD YOUR ADMINISTRATION BE
ABLE TO WILLING TO DO HAD AN?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE EXPANDED NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT THAT WOULD ENCOMPASS
BALLISTIC MISSILES AND REGIONAL
ISSUES AS WELL?
>> Translator: MY SERIES
PROPOSAL IS FOR THEM TO RETURN
IN AN EXPEDIENT MANNER TO THEIR
COMMITMENTS AND DO AWAY WITH
SANCTIONS IN DOING SO WOULD
PROVE THEIR SINCERITY.
REGIONAL AND MISSILE ISSUES ARE
NOT UP FOR NEGOTIATIONS.
>> Reporter: RAISI SAYING IRAN'S
BALLISTIC MISSILE PROGRAM IS NOT
UP FOR NEGOTIATION.
IRANIANS ARE SAYING REGIONAL
ISSUES AS FAR AS IRAN'S ACTIONS
IN THE REGION ARE ALSO NOT UP
FOR NEGOTIATION WITH THE UNITED
STATES OR ANYBODY ELSE.
THE IRANIANS DID SAY, AND
EBRAHIM RAISI SAID THEY PLAN TO
BE ACTIVE IN THIS REGION AND
AROUND THE ENTIRE WORLD BUT, OF
COURSE, IN THIS REGION
SPECIFICALLY.
ONE OTHER THINGS FROM THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE, EBRAHIM RAISI IS IN
FAVOR OF CONTINUING
NEGOTIATIONS, FOR INSTANCE, WITH
SAWED A ARABIA, TO TRY TO GET
THOSE RELATIONS SOMEWHAT BACK ON
TRACK.
THOSE HAVE ALREADY BEEN STARTED
UNDER THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION.
HE ALSO SAID THAT NOTHING IS
GOING TO CHANGE AS FAR AS ISRAEL
IS CONCERNED FOR IRAN AT ALL
UNDER THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION.
BECKY?
>> FASCINATING TO HEAR HIM TALK
ABOUT SEEKING SOME SORT OF
NEGOTIATION WITH SAUDI ARABIA
AND REOPENING THE EMBASSY.
SOMETHING WE ARE HEARING BEHIND
THE SCENES AROUND THE REGION.
I SPEAK TO YOU FROM ABU DHABI
HERE.
THESE COUNTRIES SEEKING BETTER
RELATIONS, AS IT WERE, WITH
IRAN.
THAT'S CERTAINLY GOING ON BEHIND
THE SCENES IF NOT THE HEADLINE
ALL THE TIME.
FRED, YOU SPOKE TO SOMEONE
CONSIDERED AN UP AND COMING, AS
IT WERE, IN THE IRANIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU ASKED HIM ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY.
WHO WAS IT, AND WHAT DID HE TELL
YOU?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS DEPUTY FOREIGN MINISTER
OF IRAN A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO,
IN THE EARLY STAGE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS VERY WELL
ENTRENCHED IN THE FOREIGN
POLICY, VERY CLOSE TO RAISI AND
HIS PEOPLE AND VERY MUCH IN THE
KNOW ABOUT WHAT THE FOREIGN
POLICY OF THE EBRAHIM RAISI
ADMINISTRATION WILL LOOK LIKE
AND SHAPING THAT POLICY AS WELL.
THE MAIN TAKEAWAY WE HAVE FROM
HIM IS THAT THERE WILL BE AN
ACTIVE AND VERY DYNAMIC FOREIGN
POLICY, ESPECIALLY IN THIS
REGION, BUT ALSO, INDEED, AROUND
THE WORLD.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A FOREIGN
POLICY PLANNED FOR IRAN, WHICH
VERY MUCH FOCUSES ON IRAN'S
NATIONAL INTERESTS.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> Translator: I BELIEVE THE
FOREIGN POLICY UNDER MR. RAISI
WILL BE DYNAMIC.
THE FOREIGN POLICY TOWARDS ALL
COUNTRIES WITH A LOGICAL AND AT
THE SAME TIME STRONG DISCOURSE
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO SECURE
IRANIAN RIGHTS ON ALL FRONTS.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK THE
RELATIONS WITH THE UNITED STATES
WILL EVOLVE UNDER EBRAHIM RAISI?
HE HAS BEEN VERY CRITICAL IN THE
PAST
>> Translator: THE UNITED STATES
HAS CONSTANTLY LOST
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS WILL BE MUCH DEPENDENT ON
U.S. BEHAVIOR, FOR THEM TO
DETERMINE HOW THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
ADJUST THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
IRAN.
>> Reporter: IS THERE A
DIFFERENT FEELING, THOUGH,
TOWARD THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THAN THERE
WAS TO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION?
>> Translator: I BELIEVE THAT
BIDEN IS SEEKING TO RETURN TO
THE NUCLEAR AGREEMENT.
HE SHOULD NOT BE BRINGING NEW
THINGS UP, LEGION THE REGION,
MISSILES AND INTERFERING IN
IRAN'S AFFAIRS AND THE U.S.
SHOULD FOCUS ON THE RETURN TO
THE JCPOA AND COMMITMENTS THEY
HAVE UNDER THE AGREEMENT.
>> DO YOU HAVE FAITH THAT THE
IRAN AGREEMENT WILL COME BACK ON
TRACK?
>> Translator: I ASSUME AT THE
MOMENT WHERE THE INTEREST OF OUR
PEOPLE WILL BE SECURED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE JCPOA CAN
BE STARTED.
>> Reporter: THAT, OF COURSE,
FEEDS INTO THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT, BECKY,
AT THE TOP OF THE SHOW, THAT ARE
ONGOING CURRENTLY IN VOTENA.
THIS INCOMING ADMINISTRATION,
RAISI ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT'S
POSSIBLE TO BRING THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT BACK.
OBVIOUSLY, THE CURRENT IRANIAN
ADMINISTRATION, ALL THE
NEGOTIATORS WHO ARE THERE IN
VIENNA OR HAVE BEEN THERE IN
VIENNA, THEY HOPE TO GET THAT
DONE BEFORE EBRAHIM RAISI TAKES
OFFICE.
WITH A NEW ADMINISTRATION, A LOT
OF DIFFERENT NEGOTIATORS WOULD
BE COMING TO VIENNA.
A